vous êtes les pousses de philippe
guillot qui a disparu le 10 juillet
dernier et mari de ses trois filles
merci d'être là alors c'est vrai qu'il
était chauffeur de bus à bayonne il a
été violemment agressé 5 juillet dernier
pour avoir demandé tout simplement à des
passagers de son bus de mettre un masque
il est décédé des suites de cette
agression 10 juillet il avait 58 ans il
était chauffeur de bus depuis 32 ans
il attendait la retraite pour l'été 2021
trois filles donc marie manon 21 ans et
mélanie 24 ont deux individus sont
poursuivis pour homicides volontaires
sur un agent de réseau de transport
public et deux autres pour non
assistance à personne en danger
l'afer est en cours non déjà la première
question qui ont envie de vous poser
véronique et marie déjà je vous vois
déjà très ému en voyant cette photo
c'est dans quel état vous êtes depuis 5
juillet dernier
on vit plus on survit
on essaie d'avancer on se lève on n'a
pas vraiment de but yann combat qui va
se prépare qui se prépare mais vous
voyez cette photo mais nos trois nanas
mon époux et moi même voilà c'est novik
sont détruites
ça vient lui elle est détruite il y en a
quatre sont détruites aussi et on survit
en voilà au quotidien on fait des choses
mais c'est très dur c'est la souffrance
et les terribles désarroi il est présent
jour et nuit on essaie de se raccrocher
à des souvenirs des petites choses mais
ça fait deux mois
aujourd'hui je pour jour il est parti on
a l'impression que ça fait une éternité
qu'on l'a pas vu et on sait qu'on doit
juste comme ça mais on ne peut pas vivre
comme ça voilà alors c'était donc le 5
juillet dernier
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il faisait le
tram ce jour là il devait pas travailler
il a remplacé quelqu'un voilà parce
qu'ils se rendaient service entre eux et
mais bon voilà il a travaillé et il a
pris quatre personnes trois la gare une
abolition
et il a voulu contrôler enfin déjà n'ya
pas le masque le masque est obligatoire
dans les puits partout d'ailleurs et ils
sont montés avec un chien type pitbull
ou je sais pas trop
elle intervient aussi dans les
transports en commun bien évidemment
sans muselière
apparemment je dis bien apparemment
parce que je n'ai pas vraiment la
version exacte mais je dise que c'est un
petit peu et voilà il abolit donc il a
été voir ces personnes pour demander de
mettre le masque est demandé de
contrôler leur titre de transport
sauf que ces partis en insultes donc il
est allé les voir y est allé vers lui
il est allé vers eux voilà des sorties
de ce cabinet oui oui pour aller les
voir voilà il fallait mettre le masque
le masque vous savez c'est pour nous
pour les autres pour tout le monde donc
relate les autres personnes qui étaient
dans le bus avait le masque faut que
tout le monde respecte sa set c'est très
important aujourd'hui donc là il est
dans le bus devait lui beaucoup de monde
dans le bus je pense alors je sais pas
quand je vous disais à cheval heures
voilà je pense 7 8 personnes maximum
mais je ne sais pas vraiment voilà donc
et tout est parti voilà en insulte au
clash et puis la suite on la connaît
il a été roué de coups et ainsi de suite
oui on se dit vous êtes vous êtes à la
maison ce moment-là vous apprenez la
nouvelle comme je suis à la maison ouais
j'en prends un nouvel as marqueur ferme
j'apprends la nouvelle non on me
téléphone à 20h12 exactement pour me
dire qu'on un ami à nous qui est venu
nous chercher pour me dire que philippe
est à l'hôpital
donc je le croyais pas je n'y arrivais
pas non pas philips il est venu me
chercher entre est un peu plus mes
filles qui étaient sortis puisque
c'était leur amie pour qu'elle rentre à
la maison voilà qu'elle soit la maison
quand journée l'hôpital
donc ce chauffeur venu me chercher on
est parti on a été au bureau des
urgences j'ai prononcé jeudi soir je
suis un idiot et mais vous dit pas
pourquoi vient on cherche juste non
voilà un nom il me dit rien c'est un ami
c'est un ami vous de philippus oui un
ami proche de 30
tu te trompe pas on va dire lui qui
l'envoie il travaille et que philippe
pas du tout exactement il travaille dans
l'entreprise de philippe oui d'accord
et voilà donc je l'arsel dans la voiture
parce que je veux savoir
il sait pas où il s'est mis dans la
voiture ils ont paniqué il est paniqué
voilà il est paniquée moi je suis
paniqué aussi donc il nous tarde
d'arriver aux urgences en fait
et j'arrive au bureau et je me présente
madame guillaume médecin nissan inc
était de dos je le revois quand c'était
hier vous voyez et quand il a entendu
mon prénom
entretenez et mais j'ai lu dans ses yeux
il m'a dit je m'occupe de vous suit
effectivement j'ai pas attendu
on n'a pas attendu il nous a reçus de
suite et il m'a demandé a donné sens mon
époux je mets 10 5 août 1961 et j'aimais
dit je veux le voir de suite il m'a dit
non il au bloc je me dis vous l'opérer
coin il m'indique la tête j'ai compris
deuxième fois que ont leur reer est plus
j'ai lu dentiste pas du tout compte de
l'histoire
non là donc vous arrivez à l'hôpital
louis-h vous voyez le médecin donc
qu'est la wii et vous savez même pas
pourquoi votre mari est à l'hôpital je
sais juste que ces faits graisser c'est
tout quand je n'en savais pas plus soit
là ouais d'accord
oui des touches c'est juste que c'était
une agression mais voilà après je savais
pas jusqu'à se met ça me dise
l'opération de la tête
non là là vous sentez tout de suite que
c'est très grave
oui mais je l'avais vu savez quand je
les ai déjà dit je vais j'ai senti que
c'est déjà grave parce que quand il
s'occupait de nous dans cergy ce
monsieur à ce médecin et j'ai dit non
non non non c'est pas possible quoi et
effectivement j'avais raison et du coup
à la il a human une opération de la tête
et il m'a dit que c'était très grave et
je lui ai dit les mains comme celles
comme si je faisais une prière vous
savez je lui ai dit 30eme le
rendez meuli un peu sèche voyez un petit
peu virulente ma façon de parler mais
voilà mais je voulais qu'il me rende
mais je savais qu'ils me rendraient pas
je n'ai vu je n'ai ressenti et au plus
profond de moi je les sentiers j'avais
raison
il m'a pas répondu on est parti je suis
parti je suis partie conjointe de nos
fils maison voilà partie de l'hôpital
laï-yu oui tout cas il était qualité
dans le temps il était en blocs
opératoires donc ensuite il partait en
réanimation
c'est ça ouais pas rentrer à la maison
les filles étaient là et je crois je
leur ai dit papa il est entre la vie et
la mort au jeu mais moi je réalisais pas
à faire je réalise toujours pas de
julien benneteau après voyez je je je
peux pas réaliser je peux j'ai
l'impression que je vais le revoir alors
que je sais que je ne reverrais plus
mais je voudrais tellement avoir un
baiser volé c'est ce que j'ai dit à mes
fils autres hugo mon jardin je voudrais
qu'il ne sommes qu ils m'embrassent
mexique je pourrai plus et c'est dur
c'est super dur c'est bon je sais pas
comment on va faire un défi je leur ai
dit papa est entre la vie et la mort et
et on est reparti à l'hôpital j'ai fait
4 je fais que téléphoner jusqu à savoir
quand est-ce qu'on pouvait aller le voir
on appartient à une heure du matin on
été reçus par neurologue et part de ces
firmes y est ok j'ai demandé est-ce
qu'ils sont hostiles tant elle est
engagée on m'a répondu oui de suite oui
vous l'avez pas dit avant le médecin nom
et mon frère qui était là aussi qui nous
donnaient la main on se devait la mettre
tous ensemble parce qu'on voulait pas
entendre ce qu'on a entendu en fait
briller ses seins
c'est une question d'heures or quand
vous entendez ça non ça peut pas être
une question d'heures quoi c'est ma vie
c'est notre hui et on n'a pas le droit
de faire ça on n'a pas le droit de nous
l'arracher simplement pas possible quoi
et du coup on a été le voir tout et
c'était bien philippe c'était bien lui
et était vous avait espéré manque ce qui
est qui est une erreur c'est ça oui
c'était bien lui oui enfin l'erreur si
vous voulez way peut-être pas de suite
mais aller jusqu'à jusqu'à qu'ils soient
dans son cercueil en fait j'ai sg
inspiré que ce soit pas lui dans un
cercueil jusqu'à là jusqu'à la fin a
envoyé et je me suis accroché voilà des
choses et et en fait non c'était lui et
et mais je voulais pas jouer je voulais
le le tirer de tout ça joue le contre
moi je voulais je sais pas comment je
peux m'exprimer mais on l'a vu oui à
l'hôpital à l heure du matin chez il
était branché partout niveau des bras il
a passé cinq jours dans le coma c'est ça
il était déjà quand le samu je vais vous
dire car le samu il est venu le chercher
à la red bull était déjà dans un coma
profond
déjà et et on a continué ses séjours
voilà les neurologues et les infirmiers
et personnel médical infirmier de cinq
sont superbes
super comment dire ils sont avec vous il
vous apporte
ils essaient de vous aider mais ils vont
jusqu'au bout de leurs possibilités mais
peuvent pas aller trop loin non plus
manière faut faire attention à ce qu'on
fait donc voilà au on a espéré mais vous
savez très vite vous avez senti que de
suite la vallée pour le revoir de suite
je les ai sentis de suite et vous savez
quand on relève la tête de que ce soit
votre époux que ce soit votre femme que
soit votre enfant que ce soit voilà
quelqu'un de cher quand vous le voyez
avec des tuyaux dans la tête
tullow qui rend partout avec un
respirateur artificiel
on peux pas le croire c'est celle
cauchemar quand on veut pas en creux
fusent on refuse tout ça et surtout qu
on avait plein de choses à faire
ensemble encore les choses alors
véronique vous
comme vous l'avez dit vous êtes rentré à
la maison pour la prendre à vous à vos
trois filles marie donc maman arrive à
la maison vous la voyez dans un état
d'abord elle nous a appelés au téléphone
d'accord elle a appelé d'ankama je crois
qu'elle m'a appelé en premier à moi pour
me dire que je rentre de suite papaye à
l'hôpital moi ce moment là bas j'allais
me faire une petite forêt sur la plage
avec un copain et c'est une bonne soirée
donc elle m'appelle et me dit ça donc on
annule tout on arrive à la maison
entre temps j'essaie d'appeler mon autre
soeur qui était aussi avec une copine
elle un peu plus loin et on connaissait
de l'appeler un moment là qu'il va la
voir et rentrent aussi et maman quand
elle est revenue à la maison donc elle a
appelé le travail de mon odeur la plus
grande
on leur dira fait rentrer mais la nuit
de suite il s'est passé quelque chose
donc au téléphone nous a rien dit juste
ampleur donc nous on se pose des
questions
elle nous dit juste qu'il s'est fait
agresser moi j'ai pas de suite pensé à
la tête j'ai pensé peut-être à des coups
de couteau parce que celle des
agressions je vais pas dire plus
fréquentes mais on va dire quant aux
agressions
on pense peut-être à des coups de
couteaux des choses comme ça et on
rentre à la maison
entre temps elle était repartie à
l'hôpital avec le collègue de papa et
après revient et voilà quand vous avez
parlé à vos filles vous leur avez dit
que c'était très grave où vous avez vous
leur avez fait part de votre ressenti ce
que vous avez ressenti à l'hôpital quand
vous m'avez dit je l'avais oui vous
l'avez dit oui ce qui est de ne plus
revoir papa
alors je leur ai dit il reviendra pas
voilà c'est le mot que j'ai c'est la
petite phrase que j'ai prononcés et
reviendra pas parce que voilà ce que
m'avait dit le le médecin qui ne team a
reçu avec notre ami chauffeur de bus
aussi voilà est gelé il me l'a fait
comprendre et je les ai ressenti et
voilà j'ai dit voilà ce que je dis aux
enfants il est entre la vie et la mort
mais il reviendra pas et ça véronique et
marie vous d'abord véronique qui
vous a expliqué ce qui s'était passé
parce que c'est vrai que on se dit c'est
incroyable de deux d'avoir devoir être
agressée comme ça d'être battu à mort
comme ça pour alors l'agression telle
raison voilà l'agression je ne la
connais pas véritablement j'avais voulu
en savoir plus
voilà vous savez ça fait de moi
aujourd'hui
voilà il ya une instruction est en cours
voilà il faut laisser faire il faut le
temps au temps on va dire oh là il faut
pas je ne prends mon avocat travail
les avocats de travail il faut laisser
faire moi je n'en sais pas plus
je saurai mais ce soir je peux pas vous
dire je sais qu'il est agressé je sais
qu'il a été roué de coups
je sais qu'il a été d'après ce que
j'entends aussi voilà ça a été d'une
extrême violence manière et une
conférence de presse du procureur la
république de bayonne qu'il a dit ça a
été d'une extrême violence
voilà je m'en tiens à cela pour
l'instant je le sais mais j'attends
voilà d'avoir votre version est ce que
vous avez senti depuis quelque temps que
votre mari était inquiet quand ils se
rendaient au travail ou pas du tout 6
alors philippe est quelqu'un qui gardent
beaucoup en lui mais depuis quelques
temps on se parle beaucoup
je sais pas vous en parle mais on se
parlait jeudi mal des fois à part la
mariée à l'eau présent ouais voilà
et du coup on se parlait et il me disait
je n'ai pas les gens sont agressifs les
gens ne disent pas bonjour au revoir
merci enfin je vais dire son promo qui
sont tellement important c'est la base
de tout c'est la baisse puisqu'on à
inculquer à nos enfants que je veux dire
c'est tellement évident un regard de
travers
voilà ils en avaient assez il traînait
la patte ils voulaient plus il voulait
plus élus tarnais dans un an
la retraite dans un an oui alors
c'est ça grecia ce que vous les avez
rencontré ce que vous avez des photos
d'eux est ce que vous savez de qui ce
absolument pas je ne savais absolument
rien de et de toute manière c'est moi je
ne sais rien voilà moi j'ai mon époux
dans ma tête et je l'espère
l'inscription et je veux faire confiance
à la justice
voilà moi ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui
nous en voulaient à quelqu'un
aujourd'hui
alors j'en veux ouais oui un petit peu
oui j'en veux au gouvernement
charles au gouvernement parce que j'ai
eu des soutiens c'est vrai j'ai eu de la
vie on a eu de la visite à la maison
c'est vrai de qui de du ministre de
l'intérieur
d'accord on a eu et on a eu le ballon
échappe à qui était assistant aux
qualités qui est maintenant rattaché à
l'intérieur voilà quelqu'un si aulas
était venu à la maison aussi donc
beaucoup de soutien beaucoup de paroles
beaucoup de réconfort je pensais je lui
ai d'ailleurs je leur ai dit j'ai bien
madame de chiapa j'ai dit je me rappelle
très bien aux obsèques
aidez nous voilà ce que j'ai comme ça
veut dire quoi aider ça veut dire et de
nous essayer de nous de nous faire
avancer
en prenant des nouvelles de temps en
temps en prenant on ne reste pas dans
l'oubli
voilà c'est ça la ne pas rester dans
l'oubli parce que et en fait non c'est
plus de nous
non ce soit il ya plein de gens qui
doivent se poser la question si votre
témoignage il est illettré loup vous
avez choisi de venir témoigner ce soir
deux mois exactement après la
disparition de votre mari alors merci de
m'avoir de nous avoir invités mais en
fait voilà ce qui nous est arrivé à nous
on pensait que bayonne cette petite
ville tranquille pays basque machin la
plage l'amour dans l'étau en fait non ce
qui nous est arrivé qu'on est en train
de vivre
il peut arriver à n'importe qui bien sûr
à tout le monde
aujourd'hui à n'importe qui tout voilà
n'importe quelle personne est à l'abri
de quoi que ce soit et c'est ça qu il
faut vraiment moi je demande que en on
peut entendre des paroles des paroles
des paroles d'accord des actes il faut
qu'en se sentent protégés en sécurité
enfin je sais pas quand je peux
m'exprimer
on savait je me dis les enlevant le
boulot on va au travail et maintenant le
15 juin on arrive on est inquiet parce
que est-ce qu'on va finir sk une facture
qui va tomber tout
maintenant je vais vous dire un truc tu
dis ce que tu beaucoup avec le chauffeur
de de ma ville de bayonne alors on
s'inquiète parce qu'on se demande
comment virer au moins aujourd'hui
en cinq ans en plus on s'inquiète parce
qu'on se demande s'il va rentrer chez
nous en jeu le soir voyez ce que je veux
dire mais c'est hyper grave vous sentez
en insécurité il complètement
oui tout le monde j'ai le sentiment
véronique chez parce qu'on pense les
éditorialistes autodata que ce drame
bien sûr que vous y attendiez pas mais
j'ai l'impression que vous vous dites on
était dans une telle insécurité une rien
et mon mari était tellement acquis que
quand je les abris je me suis dit
c'était pas possible que ça arrive et
c'est ça qui est grave
oui c'est vrai mais c'est très grave
mais comme je viens de vous dire est ce
qu'on se dit toujours que ça ça arrive
aux autres que ça n'arrive pas que
maintenant ça arrive pas quoi mais là
aujourd'hui on est dans une société où
tout le monde se dit ça peut nous
arriver oui oui vous étiez donc dans ce
cette optique que vous y pensiez au
départ non je pensais pas parce que on
n'a jamais eu un tel drame
au pays basque à bayonne jamais des
incivilités
on le sait c'est partout voilà à bayonne
aussi il y en a partout mais en travaux
comme s'est passé il ya deux mois jamais
on n'aurait pu imaginer ça dans notre
petit bayonne voyez ce que je veux dire
donc je ne pensais pas les sécurités à
ce moment là je pensais pas marie est ce
que vous en voulez à quelqu'un vous vous
avoir enlever votre papa
c'est sûr que c'est dur pour lui c'est
dur pour maman c'est dur pour mes soeurs
c'est dur pour moi c'est toujours pour
sa famille son entourage et tous ses
collègues mais en vouloir à quelqu'un
évidemment ces personnes là je voulais
pas qu'elle soit à cet endroit à ce
moment là évidemment mais maintenant
c'est un peu pas que c'est arrivé comme
maman elle le dit 'maintenant ça
n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
finalement et il faut des actes il faut
déjà qu'il faut voilà ils font
impression que vous en voulez enfin je
suis pas dire moi mais j'ai l'impression
vous en voulez - aux agresseurs qu'au
système c'est à dire que vous dites que
ce sont voilà c'est ils ont été mis là
par le système et ses systèmes qui a
fait naître des monstres pareil c'est
pas que j'en veux pas j'en passe des
graisseurs non pas du tout faux pas
voilà moi je
on pourra rien changer de monitrice qui
est arrivé il reviendra plus on le sait
maintenant
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure on laisse
faire l'instruction on laisse faire les
choses dans l'ordre parce qu'il faut il
faut laisser faire
maintenant moi ce que j'ai je pense à
ceux qui restent et c'est ce que je vous
disais je pense à ceux qui restent ya
chronoplus son entreprise ça et il ya
tous les chauffeurs de france voilà il
ya tout le monde en fait donc pour ces
gens là voilà même il ya d'autres mais
corps de métier aussi
c'est pareil c'est la même l'agressivité
les partout donc voilà il faut des actes
les paroles les bla bla bla bla moi je
veux bien entendre les actes alors vous
avez entendu ce témoignage chez vous
aussi
également je suis encore donc en plein
de questions à vous poser et c'est vrai
que votre message ce soir il est une
fois de plus bouleversant parce que on
voit que vous voulez avancer
oui vous voulez essayer maintenant de
protéger les autres oui ça n'arrive pas
aux autres gaspard non mais d'abord
merci pour votre témoignage et je suis
vraiment impressionné par votre courage
votre dignité
on est tout coeur avec vous après cette
épreuve terrible où traverser encore où
je vais on pense bien à vous en ces
moments qui sont partis rarement
difficile et merci encore d'avoir
accepté de témoigner
moi j'ai envie de compléter ce que vous
avez dit pas ce que vous pouvez pas le
dire et j'apprécie ce recul dont vous
faites preuve mais il ya quand même des
responsables il ya quand même des gens
qui sont des agresseurs alors bien sûr
un procès va avoir lieu
il faut quand même qu'on commence par
parler de cela parce que moi je crois en
la justice de notre pays dans l'état de
droit même s'il est imparfait et
j'attends de la justice qu'elle soit dur
comme elle doit l'être dans ce genre de
circonstance et même impitoyable envers
les agresseurs évidemment ils auront le
droit de se défendre parce que justement
dans un état de droit
ils ont le droit de se défendre avec les
- de la justice mais j'attends quand
même de la justice que l soit implacable
parce que au-delà du cas d'espèce je
pense que ça on verra aussi un signe à
la société s'ils sont punis extrêmement
dur ça je pense que c'est essentiel on
peut pas simplement dire c'est la
société il ya d'abord des coupables et
c'est d'abord eux qui doivent être
poursuivies et puis après il ya une
discussion plus large qu'on doit avoir
sur comment est ce qui se fait qui est
cet hyper violences dans la société
moi je connais un tout petit peu votre
région qui est captivant magnifique et
c'est vrai qu'on s'attendrait pas à ce
que ce genre de faits puissent
intervenir dans ce genre de quartier on
peut y mettre ou de d'endroits dans
notre pays on peut imaginer l'hyper
violence dans les zones urbaines dans
les banlieues et ce qui est vrai et ce
qui est marquant c'est que maintenant
elle frappe tout le pays toutes les
zones de façon indifférenciée
c'est le pays basque c'est l'isère c'est
la montagne des zones rurales on voit
qu'une faire financer par tous et ils en
ont réagi véronique elle disait que
avant que j'ai à bayonne volet sas ça
n'arrivait pas on n'y pensait même pas
alors gas marc gander qu'il disait
quelque chose de d'assez important
il disait il faut quand même qu'ils
soient sévèrement punis
c'est forcément c'est ce que j'ai
demandé parce que non seulement pour les
autres parce que derrière il faut que
cette sanction et cette punition et
valeur d'exemple parce que ils ont quel
âge ils ont 22 et 23 ans je croise les
agressions dans ces eaux là
et moi j'ai demandé depuis le début
voilà une peine exemplaire
voilà c'est tout ce que je demande et
maintenant
science la justice voilà en un combat on
va ramasser des courses ça veut dire une
peine exemplaire
nous avons la totalité de trente 30 ans
y'a pas la perpétuité je prends en
france je crois que voilà la peine
exemplaire c'est le sait le maximum
maximale mais le maximum voilà tout à
fait et voilà donc c'est ce que je
souhaite aujourd'hui donc c'est pour ça
je le dis encore je veux je laisse en
laisse faire l'instruction et on veut
faire confiance à la justice
bach demandant le maximum marie tooth
situe dans le je pense comme maman et
même vous voyez aujourd'hui la
perpétuité en france n'existe pas ses 30
ans et mon père il à perpétuité ça oui
ça ça fait mal de se dire que j'aimerais
savoir quel crime il a commis pour que
hui ce soit la perpétuité
voyez c'est une question j'aurais jamais
réponse j'en aurai pas des réseaux si
c'est vrai que eric naulleau ou vous
acquiescié camp oui d'abord comme tous
mes collègues chez impressionné par
votre courage suis admiratif sais pas je
pourrai le faire
moi je trouve que j'ai grandi à bayonne
même aujourd'hui naïvement je trouve
quelque chose qui colle pas entre
bayonne et la tragédie qui vous frappe
mais il faut revenir de cette naïveté
mais j'ai l'impression que le problème
est plus profond parce que en effet il
ya des mesures de sécurité mais il ya
quelque chose qui s'est déréglé dans la
société je pense pas que la sécurité
réglera pour qu'un incident aussi mineur
dégénère en drame et en tragédie que
vous allez vivre avec cette tragédie
toute votre vie il ya quelque chose qui
s'est déréglé dans les têtes et dans la
société
donc c'est pas seulement avec la
répression qu'on arrivera c'est qu'il
faut que les gens changent complètement
d'attitude et de mentalité ce sera très
long
donc commençons par faire un exemple
pour les meurtriers de votre mari de
votre de votre père mais je pense que ce
sera un travail de très longue haleine
les punir et ensuite porter ce message
que vous partez sur le sol a tout
verrouillé et marine étant donné qu'on
est en direct
j'ai un message de marlène schiappa qui
vous répond puisque vous nous aviez dit
un instant l'été venu avec donc au
ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin il faut savoir que
maintenant elle était rattachée donc
gérad marc darman à l'intérieur le
ministre de l'intérieur il vous a dit
quoi parce que je vous donner la réponse
de marine sait pas qui est maintenant
avec nous
de l'intérieur il vous a dit quoi quand
il est venu vous voir elle nous a dit
voilà comme logo et nous soutenaient et
comprenez notre tristesse c'est tout
voilà enfin ça va pas cesser c'est tout
je veux dire il vous a parlé aussi de
voilà de la suite de voix la double
enquête qu'il a des pas du tout alors
marlène schiappa vous vous envoie un
message je suis toujours à la
disposition de véronique je lui ai dit
je lui ai remis la médaille d'acte de
courage de dévouement je défends aussi
la mémoire de son mari dès qu'il ait
évoqué je pense souvent à l ac 3
formidable film on prend des nouvelles
par l'intermédiaire du préfet nous on
respecte aussi sa tranquillité la
séparation des pouvoirs car il ya une
enquête en cours
je lui ai dit que j'étais à sa
disposition et bien sûr je le suis
toujours
elle est très courageuse de venir rendre
hommage à son mari on sera toujours avec
m c'est une femme exceptionnelle et vous
avez bien fait de l'invité je reçois
j'entends d'accord voilà vous alors on
espère que voilà il faut des choses vont
bouger
c'est je crois la jambe parce que on va
pas se mentir tous ici et tous ceux qui
nous regardent ce soir à 21h52 je trouve
très mesuré véronique est mal parce que
je suis persuadé que tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent mois
voilà j'aurais dit mais je veux vraiment
qu'ils prennent perpète comme vous avez
dit et vite et je veux que le procès
soit vite réglé et que ses agresseurs
soient vite punis parce que ça c'est
inadmissible
et d'ailleurs le fait que vous soyez
aussi patiente
vous disiez on a confiance en la justice
on va laisser la justice faire son
travail le fera le temps qu'il faudra je
vous le dis je pense que 9 personnes sur
10 qui nous regardent ce soir n'ont pas
non pas comme moi votre tenir votre
indulgence et et je trouve que c'est
génial voilà trouve franchement vous
avez un comportement admirable et c'est
vous qui avait le bon comportement
mais c'est vrai qu'on a envie que c'est
c'est franchement ccc ils sont 26
sauvage on va pas se mentir oui on vous
utiliser le mot quand la wii
ils soient soient punis et soient punis
tout de suite moi j'aurais voilà je le
pense moi là je pense que karim da
correctement agathe l'auront ce gaz par
éric mallet si c'était arrivé à notre
n'a pas si c'est arrivé être notre mari
compagnon à notre compagne et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on aimerait c'est
que le gouvernement parce que c'est une
affaire qui a été extrêmement médiatisé
nation le problème qu'on a avec ses
affaires extrêmement médiatisé c'est que
c'est médiatisé au début quand il ya le
g temps devant nous mais après très vite
ces affaires tombent dans l'oubli et les
procès qui se font deux trois ans après
on les oublie on oublie les agresseurs
on oublie la disparition de certains et
ça c'est grave c'est pour ça que je
pense et on en a parlé la dernière fois
que bien sûr qu'il ya un problème
sécuritaire mais il ya un gros gros
problème et je vous dis pour moi le plus
gros problème en france aujourd'hui il
est plus au niveau de la justice et je
sais pas si c'est une question de moyens
c'est pas si c'est une question de
lourdeurs administratives mais
aujourd'hui gaspard vous qui avez été
dans les voies la mine de rien on entend
dans le coeur du moteur je vous dis
aujourd'hui
moi quand je vois véronique et conjointe
marie je me dis on peut pas attendre et
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en france
pourquoi on peut aller vers une dérive
incroyable au niveau de niveau
sécuritaire et au niveau des citoyens
c'est qu'il peut y avoir une guerre
civile parce qu'il ya plein de gens je
vous dis tu aurais dit pas moi je vais
aller me faire justice moi-même mais ces
mots clés ce cas d'espèce je pense que
le premier mois non la loi pénale en
tant que tel parce que les peines
exemplaires j'espère qu'elles seront
appliquées en la matière que l'on les
moyens de la justice et ça pense que la
justice en france elle a les moyens
aujourd'hui de ceux du 19e siècle on est
la honte de l'europe sur le nombre de
magistrats que ça soit les magistrats du
siège et du parquet les policiers ont
pas les moyens de mener les enquêtes et
ça prend des mois des mois des mois on
vend on le voit à travers votre drame
quand est ce que ça sera jugé si moi je
suis certainement pas dans un an dans
deux ans dans trois ans on l'a vu avec
ça n'a rien à voir
la tuerie de charlie hebdo c'est en ce
moment
1020 alors que sa date de 2015 c'est
alors oui on doit pas juger sur le coup
de l'émotion ça je pense que c'est
important qui a une nature est le
principe du contradictoire mais entre
l'émotion du quotidien est repoussé à
des procès cinq ans plus tard c'est
insupportable parce que vous j'imagine
je ne suis pas votre classe et je suis
pas dans votre détresse et j'ai pas
votre dignité surtout vous attendez que
justice soit faite et le deuil ne pourra
jamais être complet tant que la justice
n'aura pas fait son oeuvre
alors véronique et est mariée ce que
vous avez un dernier message à livrer
nos téléspectateurs ce soir déjà je
voudrais vous remercier pour votre
témoignage est d'être venu est-ce que
vous avez une dernière chose à dire mais
déjà je voudrais je voudrais on a fait
des photos j'ai fait notre photo je
voudrais que qu'elle passe je sais pas
s'il va passer
voilà le portefeuille de mon époux voilà
qui est à l'envers malheureusement elles
sont même monsieur précis mais voilà
c'était à votre ses trois filles ses
trois filles moi même et il a toujours
eu ça dans son portail nous étions cinq
extrêmement soudée voilà l'endroit et on
est plus que 4 on va se battre pour lui
mais voilà je voulais il ya l'arrêt de
bus aussi que je j'entretiens de temps
en temps je voudrais qu'il passe voilà
c'est la red bulls où philippe a trouvé
l'amour et je voudrais vous la faire
passer aux gens qui m'ont les
spectateurs à vous tous ici voilà
l'arrêt de bus alors au bcmo fille on va
changer les roses de temps en temps
quand elles sont en plein soleil mais
malheureusement ma fille aînée a fait le
coeur avec les petites bougies
voilà donc on essaie d'entretenir cet
endroit on y va de temps en temps on va
au jardin du souvenir au vin partout là
où voilà vous avez compris voilà donc en
fait je mets 10 avec lui comment là on a
des souvenirs avec est complètement de
toute manière je vous dire j'ai que
c'est qu'en deux ans mais mon mari sera
toujours mon mari qui soit qu'ils sont
avant et même aujourd'hui qu'il n'est
plus là ce sera toujours mon époux est
gelée là je vais là et ça restera là bas
tout le temps
le paysage à lire oui je vais je suis né
avec le message que je voulais faire
passer à tous
il ya un groupe en soutien flip mauguio
voilà sur les réseaux sociaux qui est
extrêmement important j'ai ensuite nous
avons pardon mes filles et moi même un
soutien qui est fabuleux et vous tous
voilà vous êtes si vous êtes là aussi
c'est que vous nous soutenez je pense et
je voudrais vous en remercier je vous
connais pas mais c'est mon coeur qui
parle
mes tripes et vivait souriez nous on a
un petit peu oublié un sourire on a
oublié un petit peu notre vie parce que
parce qu'il n'est plus là mais voilà
prenez soin de vous surtout et voilà est
resté avec nous pour qu'on puisse
avancer le plus correctement possible
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire à tous
[Musique]
marie
marié ce que vous l'avez dernier mot
après si je pense que vous êtes très
fier de votre maman complètement quand
vous êtes normalement nous représentent
ne respirez l'amour avec papa et moi
aujourd'hui je veux juste faire moi je
parle aussi pour mes soeurs pour ma mère
on veut que la sécurité incombe
maintenant quand on marche dans la rue
ou camperait quand on prend le bus ou
quoi que ce soit qu'on se sente
insécurité qui est pas une deuxième papa
qu'ils soient arrachés vous voyez où une
deuxième maman parce qu'il ya des
conductrices aussi où que ce soit dans
n'importe quel métier je veux pas que
une deuxième famille soit mon même s'il
y en a plein en france passe on est dans
le monde que d'autres familles soient
aussi bouleversée par la perte d'un
proche et et soudaine
c'était même papa ben moi je tiens juste
à dire quelques mots sur lui valait un
peu pas extraordinaire un sacré monsieur
un sacré monsieur savez j'ai fait le 26
août
on aurait dû fêter nos 25 ans de mariage
le 26 août la le 27 août ya le nc tout y
est mais l'anniversaire de notre fille
aînée 24 ans et on n'a rien fait et on
n'a rien fait parce que c'est tout
simplement pas possible on sait qu'il y
aura plus d'un anniversaire
on sait que les noël seront
catastrophiques ans et on sait tout ça
mais voilà alors oui il faut que la
justice nous entendent vraiment mais
vraiment vraiment le deuil je le ferai
jamais je le ferai jamais parce que ça
va même si lui et moi on a fauté dans
notre vie à deux on s'est toujours dit
jamais l'un sans l'autre et en fait on
nous l'a arraché on me lâche et donc
voilà c'est ça sera lui tout le temps la
justice doit vraiment nous entendre pour
que je dis là on essaye de faire le
deuil mais je ferai jamais monde ait
jamais ça donc merci véronique un
premier signal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]